merci georges beaucoup de choses
intéressantes ont beaucoup de choses
intéressantes ont été dites et je crois
en particulier dans l'intervention de
d'alexandre glaris en rentrant d'un son
de de détail et de modalités opératoires
qui me paraissent essentiels la réalité
des peines la cohérence des peines c'est
éric l'a très bien dit une affaire
d'autorité tout à fait essentiel moi je
souhaitais simplement peut-être de
manière un peu original mais venir sur
deux points qui me paraissent importants
parce que je pense que si l'on veut
assurer la réalité la cohérence des
peines il faut qu'il n'y ait aucun tabou
le premier c'est la question de la
double peine notre majorité en son temps
à supprimer la double peine je pense que
c'était une erreur et je pense que
lorsqu'une personne étrangère est
sanctionné par une peine d'un certain
quantum la double peine à son
exemplarité sa logique et sa cohérence
et je pense que la réalité des peines au
delà de bien d'autres projets que l'on
peut avoir
il est important de démontrer à nos
concitoyens que nous en assurons la
réalité la cohérence aujourd'hui ce
n'est plus le cas je pense que c'est là
une atteinte au pacte social et au pacte
civique
lorsqu'une personne est sur le
territoire la république
elle jouit de droits elle a des devoirs
lorsqu'elle ne respectent pas le pacte
républicain alors la personne n'a pas sa
place sur le territoire la république et
je pense que la cohérence des peines
passe entre autre proposition par le
rétablissement de la double peine
deuxième point sur la réalité des peines
nous en avions déjà discuté il ya
quelques mois
c'est un sujet qui est un peu revenu
dans le débat public et je ne pense pas
que notre famille politique puisse y
échapper il y a dans le droit des
sanctions trop faible pour des actes
graves et cela doit être renforcée dans
la sanction et l'exécution de la fonte
la sanction ça vient d'être très bien
dit il y a parfois des sanctions trop
forte sur des actes
alors j'entends bien qui vole un oeuf
vole un boeuf mais a tout de même un
bout de sujets qui à un moment fait que
des personnes sont potentiellement
passible de sanctions jamais appliquées
sauf le jour où elles le sont et ça rend
le système judiciaire extrêmement
compliqué à comprendre et l'autorité de
la justice
l'autorité de l'état la réalité des
peines
c'est aussi de mon point de vue
actualisée cela mais quelle est la
logique derrière cela cette sphère que
les peines que l'on encourt
potentiellement soit réellement encourus
et qu'il y ait véritablement une
sanction et ça amène à aborder la
question d'un deuxième tabou dont je
pense dès lors qu'on parle d'autorité et
de sécurité justice qu'on ne peut pas le
laisser à l'état de tabou
c'est la question de la sanction
appliquée à la consommation de drogues à
la consommation de stupéfiants dans
notre pays
la société française est sur ce sujet en
pleine hypocrisie et cette hypocrisie
est une atteinte grave à l'autorité de
l'état est en réalité à la sécurité et à
la justice puisque des millions de
personnes qui commettent des délits
commettre ce délit
en sachant qu'elles ne seront d'aucune
manière punis vous ne construisez pas un
système judiciaire
vous ne construisez pas l'autorité de
l'état sur de tels non dits et de telle
hypocrisie
je fais une proposition précise c'est
une proposition que je fais je la mets
dans le débat georges c'est que nous
proposions aux français un référendum
pour leur demander de
affirmer car c'est ma position le choix
français de refus de l'égalisation de
consommation de stupéfiants
on ne fait pas le bonheur du peuple
malgré lui il faut à un moment que nos
concitoyens prennent leur responsabilité
la france est un des pays en europe et
dans le monde où la consommation de
stupéfiants est le plus répandu
c'est un pays aujourd'hui il faut
affronter la réalité les amis la moitié
des jeunes consomment ou ont consommé
c'est la réalité en face de cette
réalité nous avons un état de droit qui
est totalement inadapté une société qui
ne vit que sur l'hypocrisie et des
politiques qui s'enfuit systématiquement
de ce débat eh bien je considère qu y
compris à droite pour assurer la
cohérence la réalité des peines et
l'autorité de la justice
c'est un débat qu'on doit assumer en
commençant par bordés aux français que
voulez vous est ce que vous confirmez
l'interdiction est la sanction de
consommation de stupéfiants
à cette question qui doit être proposée
aux français je propose de répondre oui
nous voulons confirmer cette sanction
et si les français sont dans notre avis
ils prennent leur responsabilité mais au
moins la volonté du peuple aura été
clairement exprimé ensuite que l'on est
un dispositif de sanction qui quel que
soit le nom technique qu'on lui donne
soit réellement appliquée ça ne sert à
rien de me menacer de mettre en prison
des millions de personnes parce que
c'est pas un problème de nombre de
places de prison en dizaine de milliers
ça ne sert à rien de me menacer de
mettre en prison des millions de
personnes si on ne le fait pas à quoi
ressemble notre système judiciaire dans
cette situation donc il faut munis d'un
mandat clair du peuple français que l'on
applique des sanctions applicables et
qu'elles soient réellement appliquées
il y à des pays où ça fonctionne mieux
que chez nous donc moi je voulais
simplement dire cela dans cette table
ronde
je ne me résigne pas à ce que sur des
pans considérable la moitié des jeunes
des millions de personnes on vivre dans
un pays où on dit beaucoup de choses
intelligentes et utiles sur l'évolution
de la justice
mais il y à un pan entier sur lequel on
fait une impasse en apprenant aux
jeune de france à ne pas respecter la
loi car c'est bien le sujet aujourd'hui
vous avez des millions de jeunes qui
grandissent avec l'idée que la loi c'est
quelque chose de relatif qu'en réalité
qu'en théorie il peut il encourt des
peines de prison mais qu'en réalité
personne ne les y mettra cette situation
doit être tranché par le peuple
mon idée de référendum et cette
situation doit être traitée par des
échelles réalité cohérence de la peine
par des échelles de sanction qu'on soit
véritablement en mesure d'appliquer je
vous conjure quand il s'agit d'aborder
les enjeux de justice d'autorité et de
police de les aborder y compris par ce
volet est un volet difficile c'est le
plus difficile parce que c'est celui qui
concerne le plus grand nombre de
personnes les jeunes leur famille
simplement les amis si on n'aborde pas
ce sujet on fait de la théorie et on
apporte pas à la justice à la police
l'autorité qu'elle mérite véritablement
aujourd'hui